hello everyone welcome to gamespot
gameplay as you may notice i am not
kevin van noord he is busy doing thief
work I'm Tomic che so I'm going in today
and we have a couple people to join me I
got Chris waters hey Tom hi everybody
how you doing Chris waters I am I had a
burger and a malted milkshake for lunch
so you recently started a livestream
show I did yeah multiple players on
Tuesdays every Tuesday like 11pm 11am
and yeah I'm seeing a late night show
the way that show ya know it's uh yeah
we played video games and we'll have a
new episode this coming tuesday at 11am
and also playing some pvz garden warfare
on monday afternoon oh that's very
exciting yeah that's pretty exciting so
we also have Justin hey Walt who is our
soon your senior news editor when I
brought you in october november at
justin hardcore gaming hey Walt from one
of the channels that I recently opened
up but I really surprised that you just
outed kevin van word for his peeving
yeah the reason he's not gonna be here
cuz he's a thief he's been doing a lot
of thievin recently he's a known thief
he yeah it with his hands thusly all the
time like this is what Kevin mentor does
now yeah I mean it's eat so far so good
and he's not not gotten caught like he's
not in jail or any he's not he's not in
jail haven't seen a wanted poster with
his face on it around town so I guess I
mean he does spend a lot of time
stealing hearts oh yes okay so with that
we're gonna start it off there's there's
a huge news story this week Irrational
Games who have been around for 17 years
they made System Shock she thought you
were gonna say flappy bird they made
Bioshock they made BioShock Infinite the
day they made swat4 pburg they are
winding down according to their like
creative head ken Levine I mean a lot of
outlets and us included basically said
they're shutting down his is his exact
wording was winding down but winding
down from about a hundred twenty
employees to 15 yes a lot of really
talented people are going to lose their
jobs which is a shame I've lost their
jobs have lots of jobs already ate so um
they're not just just shortly on that
like we have seen people
come from irrational and do great things
already most notably last year was gone
home so hopefully there's the tail to
people find a place isn't it and they
just shipped a hugely successful game by
binding by any metric they're not gonna
have trouble getting place to another
studio I mean that's what these guys
look for when they're trying to hire new
developers is like have you shipped a
game yeah they should Bosh I can I heard
of it well it's a little thing so I mean
my first question is irrational for all
intensive purposes is gone what is their
legacy how did they change the industry
in the 17 years that they've been around
not at all not at all this is like this
is all your thought now of course they
had a huge impact the Bioshock is is a
lot of people's favorite games um Anna
and as many problems as BioShock
Infinite had I know that you did not
enjoy that a lot it it was a lot of it
was a really fun shooter and it really I
feel like pushed narrative in ways that
and not a lot of other developers even
can do that i mean he he takes a really
artistic bent he takes he takes attack
that a lot of other triple-a shooters
like they just kind of go straight out
for fun shooting and he goes for like a
story and tries to whether whether he
was successful or not and i think a lot
of ways bow shock was a failure but he
tries to tackle tougher subjects so
Chris like I I consider them in our tour
studio they do you mean by auteur studio
like they all just like that ken Levine
is the auteur at the head of the studio
and it all sort of falls down hill from
his sort of core main vision well we'll
talk about that a little bit more later
but yeah I mean it seems like they mean
they have an artistic focus on their
games so they they're no longer gonna be
a triple a studio if if Kent Levine's
team is still a rational we don't know
what is they really mean they are no
longer going to be like the hundred
fifty person team that takes four years
and cutting-edge hardware like all that
undreds of millions of dollars they're
scaling back the size and the scale
considerably how do you think that
impacts the triple-a industry as we know
it not having this kind of studio there
anymore you mean well you know I feel
like the impact might be that like here
is a studio that you know has made some
critically acclaimed
games on countless Game of the Year
lists like multiple iterations of this
game and it's certainly hugely
influential in terms of design and
content for first-person shooters but
also just games in general seeing that
added that endeavor like go kaput like
does that did they fail but I mean
Bioshock Infinite's all well like are
they are they a financial failure cuz
that sends huge warning signs right in
terms of the triple a model but if it's
not that they are a financial failure it
then why why are they dissolving is are
they like an institutional failure like
they just couldn't come together when we
was a failure it I think it really has a
lot more to do with spending so much
time making something like this and
that's just the model of games these
days especially when we're going to xbox
one and ps4 the development time the
development teams needed to make
something on that same level yeah are
probably even larger the budgets will
need to be larger that's just not
something that I think is as supportable
and that we're going to see smaller
teams making different experiences but
and I think our definition of Triple A
is going to change because of that I
think so too and especially you know I
think one of the things that develop
certainly Epic Games has talked about is
with next gen consoles and you know this
Hardware the the kind of software it can
run the kind of game development
software it can run requires less people
less processing time less time to create
richer worlds to create like better
graphics to create all sort of the the
the baubles of a hallmarks of a triple a
title so you know as sort of technology
and the software advances can of team of
15 people put together something that
you know Stan's toe-to-toe with a
bioshock infinite of course they can
absolutely and they have been in a team
of four people have made wonderful
experience i mean gone home was a team
of what like four or five people yeah
and I in its of course not on that same
level but it was also a much shorter
experience but that was equally powerful
in some ways minecraft minecraft is
there one person so it's super yeah so I
think that you know this is it's not so
much that like the I think that
irrational Studios is setting this sort
of phasing down this sort of shutting
down is
it's just showing us a new path that
developers can sort of chart through the
industry right you know we've seen we
are on a different scale I guess because
we've seen people you know move up in
the world they join bigger and bigger
developers and they're working on that
huge game and that like makes their
career and then they can work on their
next huge game in a huge game in a huge
game but a lot of people do that huge
game and they're like okay well that was
super intense I don't know if I can
handle that and I think that it's nice
to see this kind of diversification of
career paths for a game developer and if
I was a game developer you know
obviously having 100 people laid off
from a studio is not heartening but
having high profile developers sort of
investing like saying no this smaller
team this is actually a better way to go
is like seems more heartening to me in
terms of the diversity of future job
opportunities and in some ways we've
seen this coming for a while I mean you
can never guess when so many layoffs are
going to hit but we've seen more be tier
c.t.r developers kind of being phased
out like they're there really are no see
to your meteor games anymore it's either
very low budget put together very
quickly or these huge large budget
Triple A games and of course that's
something that's going to happen less
and less because there's just not the
time and money when you can do really
amazing experiences with smaller teams
on a faster cycle of course that's gonna
win out over spending three years and
millions and millions of dollars that is
very true so just just going back a
little too irrational is so I mean a lot
of the conversation and myself included
we're talking about how we're excited to
see what kind of eyes go to next because
he's you know he's kind of brilliant in
some ways do you think we give too much
credit to ken Levine and similar heads
of giant triple-a studios or do you
think this it's appropriate yes you know
but if you want a hundred percent like I
mean that's that is the way that we
think about things it's really easy to
have like this is the figurehead ken
Levine is bioshock he is the creator but
I mean that's silly there are hundreds
of people that go into making these
games just like movies when you finish a
movie and at the end you see the credits
rolling you're like oh yeah that was a
Steven Spielberg movie like well no is
all these other people it so so I went
to as an example i went to the Star Wars
behind-the-scenes thing this weekend and
you know we think of George
Lucas as having created this world and
yeah he had a large part in creating the
wonderful episode four five and six but
when you have the the behind-the-scenes
guys talking about it the people that
actually made these models that made at
work it was not just George Lucas if if
he didn't have this amazing team of
Industrial Light & Magic these people
putting these models together finding
ways to make them fly through space the
movies would have been crap they they
would not have survived just on the
power of his script and so but that you
know and that's obviously true you know
whenever you have a huge team everyone's
pulling together and certainly the
leadership matters the leadership the
creative vision that artistic vision
that is an important role on the team
but it's a role on the team the converse
of that is we do live in a culture of
celebrity and of we want to give one
person credit for it we want to admire
one person we want to put them on a
pedestal we want to be like oh this is a
Shinji Mikami game like I'm totally down
with this like and to a certain extent
that has you know that has value in in
sort of your from a pert from a gamers
decision point like it you know you kind
of know what something coming out of
naughty dog is gonna be like but that
even Naughty Dog like his Neil druckmann
like that's not even that's not one of
those studios it has the one name is
Neil druckmann and Bruce Straley yeah
it's those two guys Amy Hennig also yeah
he does the Uncharted so there's three
you just named three people yeah not one
you know like I think that it's
interesting to see you know it's
interesting just sort of cultural
reflection of where games are to see
these kind of you know figures emerging
and becoming discussed more and you know
I think it's just sorts just sort of a
natural progression into pop culture is
that you try to sort of pin it to Cliff
Bleszinski or Shigeru Miyamoto and stuff
like that and you know I think it it's
kind of cool to have those names to have
those those single names then I guess
real quick with this because we have the
Raptors up at some point but the reverse
to that is like Derek you mate spelunky
and in a trick McMillan and and Tommy
made super meat boy and Jonathan Blow
made braid and it's like so clearly this
is their creative vision and it is
realized on screen and there's very few
other people who helped if any at all uh
could you argue that ken Levine ken
Levine his vision is bioshock infant
and he had other people to help with the
art and help with the music but this is
his vision on the disk on the screen
that's what we're seeing what do you
think that's still too much credit when
you get to something of that scope and
that magnitude I some of that has to
fall apart like you do you rely on your
your cinematographer to use the movie
example you rely on your cinematographer
to find these scenes too and there they
actually have a really big part even
though you're it's your idea in the
first place they have a big part in how
that movie looks or you write the script
and the actors are the ones who actually
give it the weight and motorable actors
can meet can break a movie okay and you
have studios like rocket if you're Tomic
shay and you love terrible movies or
you're Tom Cruise you just make every
movie yes that is true like think about
rock star what I mean we know Sam Houser
because he's this crazy reclusive guy
but rock star studios themselves never
have a front facing spokesperson for the
game like there is no Grand Theft Auto
spokesperson yeah it is elective
Blizzard doesn't really have that I
don't know who made half life two
there's a few studios who works just
like no it's a team effort and there's
other ones works like no Shigeru
Miyamoto he's been making everything by
hand for the last 30 years which raises
the interesting question how much are
these people created and encouraged sort
of cultivated as a PR move I mean if
your student if you have if you're not
just someone coming from irrational
games but you're like creative founder
and creative director ken Levine his
vision like that's the one that people
are going to want to talk to on their
show that's one that people are gonna
want to attach that to and that's that's
the thing that's going to be able to
like drive that maybe elevate that PR
cycle into a into one more mainstream
like if mainstream media can get their
hooks into it they're not going to want
someone to come on PR team to just come
off and show the game you're gonna want
that head that person to talk to that's
that's I mean suda51 hasn't directed
games it's no more heroes two but we
always talk about sudah because he's
everything with grasshoppers so that is
true yeah so there's another story this
week that's all that's kind of a
non-story right now but I thought it
could be interesting so amazon amazon
has a set-top box coming out and it's
going to be like Apple TV problem it's
going to come out rumored to be in March
and it's basically in a stream hulu and
amazon and all
other stuff to tell us Netflix all that
good stuff run she roll I was gonna say
I couldn't think of a crunchy roll on
zoo and it's supposed to also use the
Android architecture so it kind of
sounds like it could be like legs could
this be the next to via well it's like
the kindle fire except the pleasure TV
so Julia too there's a new yacht to so
may it just made me think about like so
many games now are being made for the
iphone there be made for android and
make for PCs and you know you know
people really want a way to play those
on their TV I gave spoken loud and clear
that you use sone crowd are you in
sarcasm I you know I I hate having that
need to be tethered to my phone i really
want to sit down on my couch need that
small screen experience on the big
screen my question was if you have
hardware that is relatively powerful and
you have it so it sets in 900 million
people's homes is it possible that we
have a step towards a one console future
where games are all that matters and not
necessarily the hardware the tackler
proprietary medium behind it or you
think that is still just a pipe dream
that is not even worth dreaming about
it's going to happen that that is you
think there will be a one council future
no no well I mean the thing is that the
console is just not going to matter I
that would be like saying there's a one
TV future a lot of people are going to
keep making TVs it the way that we
interact with it is going to change but
I think eventually the way that we think
about consoles is going to go away and
it's going to be something that we were
able to access really easily and Sony
wants to do this they want you to just
access games from your TV you don't have
to worry about purchasing the different
box you just go on your TV access
Netflix and all of the PlayStation
library but that is still proprietary
because you still need to have a sony
something-or-other to access these
somebody wants to make money from this
there has to be there has to be a
gatekeeper there's going to be a
gatekeeper because businesses okay so do
you believe that there will always be
some sort of proprietary format but it
will just become more widespread well so
talk to me about the Houthis how Sony
like so let's take PlayStation Plus
let's just say PlayStation Plus is from
you know 10 years in the future you just
have a PlayStation subscription and you
plug your TV into the internet or e plug
you have your whatever bajalo box yeah
and you buy a controller from Sony and
that's all you buy and then it's
all digital it's stored in the cloud
it's streaming to your TV what that's
like yeah what you're imagining no I
mean that is one out are you cutting out
the console or is and it is just fully
streaming directly in your TV because
TVs now badly routers on them they have
ethernet jacks like you can like you can
get amazon instant video on your TV
directly why do you even need that
set-top box what the PlayStation now
that I used when I was at a of JD at CES
earlier this year that was coming from
the TV I mean I have no idea what
bandwidth they were using I don't know
how far away their their actual systems
were but that was only a TV and a ps3
controller and it was streaming the last
of us it cut they were already cutting
out the console and that is I mean
that's really cool that is not that's
not the future that's really soon that's
the hell resin yeah and it's just how
far they going to be able to take that
how how big can our infrastructure can
handle that so that that is a streaming
service am I right yes so I guess that's
a big question is I don't know if
America which has great internet
compared to most of the world can even
handle its roomy master it may be as we
sold the xbox one first structure is not
there and then that goat raised the
question so we're probably be sold
hardware for still ten more years at
least until our internet is good so I
mean do you expect hardware to still be
like ps4 where it is like bleeding edge
or anything hardware is going to keep
getting scaled back because we don't
really need that kind of technology yeah
it's such an expensive proposition to
get into to making these this hardware I
think this could very well be the last i
I don't know i'm i'm just kind of making
this up but this could very well be the
last regular console that we see and
they're gonna take this last as long as
i can and hopefully within you know
eight years the infrastructure is big
enough that the people who would spend
money on it at least we'll be able to
get access to those games and everyone
else will be using the last gen console
okay so Chris I mean there's the people
talk about like the end of the council's
which is what people are talking about
right now sure it's usually a portent of
doom and gloom how do you think that
life gaming life will be better when
this inevitably happens how will it be
better how will it be better than what
we have now my live
room will be less cluttered I mean it
will if you don't have the hardware then
you don't have that extra cost of entry
like Justin was saying you don't have
that extra expenditure so theoretically
you're making it more affordable now of
course you also have to have a TV which
displays these things and those are
expensive everybody's got a TV but yet
this you know TV is kind of standard
Yeah right especially you know if you're
that gaming is your hobby I in terms of
like production pipeline and stuff like
that if you have no console you have no
disks and if you have no disks you have
no brick-and-mortar retailers uh except
for used sales maybe so we've seen that
doesn't affect prices that that much I
mean people people still pay sixty
dollars for a digital download of these
games nintendo nintendo has said openly
like yeah we could charge less but we're
not going to because that cheapens the
experience yeah and but then again you
know we've been paying 15 20 bucks for
premium downloadable experiences for how
long now five years maybe a little more
what happens when we been doing that for
ten years what happens when that that
price point because comes as I mean it's
already as ingrained as the 60 but like
you know as your continuingly doing
digital purchases and as places as as
Sony and Microsoft are trying to
encourage you with like day one digital
download special bonuses like get your
feather in your cap or whatever how long
till they start like shaving that price
just a little bit i mean playstation
plus they're going to shave like ten
percent off your price or even like two
bucks off a downloadable thing like that
is a tangible reason to go digital to
buy to make though those price points to
erode that or would we get less of a
game like would we get more metal gear
solid ground zeroes type experiences
where yeah it's a little cheaper but
it's also two hours you can replay it
and you know wait for the next part of
this experience which is going to be
phantom pain which will never come out
because it's too big and is that is that
the filter of say bioshock a 15-man team
can make two chapters of bioshock and
then release it and then make two more
chapters and release it and then two
more chapters and then release it do you
have these ongoing seasons i mean we
already have sort of the season based
mentality going with telltale has a
great success with them already the sea
in past thing is in place for d else is
also valve is great with their episodic
content I mean but you know if you there
are there are lots of you know lots of
teams experimenting with that kind of
content and I think that you're just as
you see as this digital you know future
is comes more and more upon us I think
the articulation of price points is only
going to get more diverse as people try
to find ways to entice you to pay for
that game I guess that's that's the
question that that's been haunting I
mean because it's price points is scary
because free-to-play is often bad it is
it is often bad is it not not always
lean legends as it well dota 2 times 0
ft $60 games are often bad fifty sixty
dollar games are also often bad because
they spend so much money on like look at
how good this game looks and then you're
getting a game that seven hours long or
getting a game it's reliant on other
people to make it fun cuz it's all
multiplayer so how do you think pricing
will change when like all of a sudden
everything is equal every game is on
every platform and it's just a pure
meritocracy and that is it's like will
we still see dungeon keeper on mobile
type business plans we still see the
sixty dollar games well I mean I feel
like I'm going back on what I said
before Layton and not every game is
going to be on every platform and I
think there will always be a Nintendo
like okay there will always be e a
gatekeeper like them who wants a very
specialized experience and will try to
provide the for them the purest way to
experiences do you think do you think
endo because if Nintendo is still
struggling to sell do you think that
they can keep doing that and supposed to
like we're gonna release our games for a
900 million dollar or 900 million person
audience well I mean they just they
Nintendo is very willing to experiment
and we've seen sometimes they're
successful like with the wii sometimes
they're not successful with the wii u
yeah but they're still so really really
successful with the 3ds their handhelds
are selling like gangbusters i mean to
say that they're not doing well is to
completely ignore the 3ds um it's things
like the wii u like maybe they they will
probably move away from doing stuff like
that if the next iteration of this is a
failure
it I think they will always have
companies that like to to experiment and
to push the boundaries of of how we
interact with that hardware and we will
also always have companies that are
holding on to their games and this is
the only way you can get their content
because we've already see I mean we see
this playing out already with content
battles in the TV realm you know CBS is
there you you're you know you're only
watching like very few of their shows on
Hulu or on netflix mostly you got to go
through CBS com uh that's why Amazon and
Netflix and Hulu have all sunk millions
and millions of dollars in creating
their own original content because
there's this believe there's this belief
that you know you can like but creating
the content owning it's indicating it
that's where like that's the most
profitable endeavor that's where you
really have power is if you're creating
that content not just if you're
distributing that content so you know in
this sort of future of you know the this
breakdown of like you need this specific
box to play this thing you're still
you're going to need this subscription
to xbox live to play this thing because
those companies are always going to hold
on to something yeah to something and
not just try to throw it all out there
and may the best game win so maybe
eventually the hardware will kind of
disappear but the then its place will
rise up PlayStation now basically or
well the hardware become part of our
clothing and we have to get into our
gaming suits are you loaded on gaming a
trap on the oculus strapon but all of
the things and then the insertion things
the external fluid catching things yeah
and that's how you experience aardvark
in your phone it's all gonna be in your
phone it comes out from under the TV
goes into your spinal cord and you just
like I was pretty fun I like the last
part special I don't want have to move
so finally uh what do you think Amazon's
chances are to even compete in the
console space of although I mean they
have an uphill battle coming coming to
to gamers who are already so jaded about
the the heavyweights about the Microsoft
and Sony having a contender that I mean
when I think about it I think kuya and
that's not a that's not a great
comparison they'll run off with Amazon's
a little bigger more trusted to do you
have any but like what did they even
wanna
Pete against a xbox one or a playstation
4 I mean this the set-top box it's been
rumored and is going to be coming out
pretty soon probably is just like you
said it's a Roku competitor it's an
apple TV competitor yep that market is
already saturated like there are just
straight-up TVs that do that stuff and
you don't even have to buy that box like
up I don't I mean obviously the name
amazon has super brand power but does
but how much power does it really have
cuz i watch amazon video through my xbox
one i could watch it through any number
of things that i already have uh you
know i'm down with the service and with
buying stuff from them but do but it's a
whole different leap to do i invest in
that hardware because then that hardware
has to have a value proposition it's
distinct from what I already have I know
they're trying to play catch-up they're
coming at the at the tail end of this it
feels like like that race is already run
and they're about halfway to the finish
line and it feels like you're oh you
know I'm gonna come and catch up huh I
could get you guys so they kind of did
that too with the with the iPad and the
other Android tablets and the kindle
fires done really well so I mean it is
possible that to be the late comer and
still have a success true but also you
know the tablet market and people's like
fervor for tablets throw them out every
year Dave ryan/the garbage then they get
a new one that's I mean that kind of
technophile that kind of like product
lust and appetite I feel like has been
growing exponentially in recent years
whereas you know roku's stuff to stream
this stuff is not like people want to
have it but it's not like the sexy thing
no no okay and it is there they
introduced a more powerful tablet it's
cheaper um that that is a really
appealing proposition plus it's called
the fire yeah it's great that can link
it comes from the kindle and it's fire
and i really like my Kindle so there's
one other like story that I thought was
interesting this week other people might
not twitch plays Pokemon alright so this
is this is basically like someone
figured out a way to stream pokemon red
and then the users in the chat would
type in you know left or right or
whatever control they wanted to be the
protagonist to do and that the
protagonist would do it and so you have
80,000 plus people at once trying to
control everything
on the controller getting their inputs
the cheeto paws all over it's just
madness it went up to a hundred twenty
thousand five hundred twenty thousand
concurrent users went on it's been going
for nine straight days it is it is a
phenomenon that will probably burn out
really quickly well nobody mean really
quickly it's been going on for a week um
that's that's that's keeping that Sophie
a lot longer than flappy bird was that's
longer than some relationships so what
is it that is appealing about this
Justin do you have any idea I was so
surprised when I first saw this and I
heard about it was like oh yeah that's
kind of funny and it's so frustrating to
watch because it's just like this
[ __ ] like I'm moving back before open
I need to look at the helix faucet like
there's a religion that's grown up
around the observing the helix fossil
like there are people in the chat who
are just like all praise the helix basic
on can you talk about that because i
don't i don't think most people know
what you're talking about it's it
there's so many facets of this craziness
so I mean it started off with just
people trying to fight to move their
character and to win the game but you of
course you have people who are
anarchists who want to watch this game
burn poker Charles and and so for you
know one of the items that they
collected was the helix fossil of course
they're never going to be able to use it
because that would take a weird
coordinated effort so helix fossil you
go to a specific point in them game and
you use it to resurrect some kind of
like law so Sigma yeah and so people
have built up in an Internet religion
what is it now at at 75,000 people some
of them have an Internet religion around
the helix fossil as their God and they
some of the pokemon are their profits oh
and Jay Leno and and Abby are the
prophets who died in in trying to save
the world there's a false prophet
pokemon in the party now there's the
whole democracy versus Anarchy mechanic
which basically like if it the slider
goes to democracy then the majority vote
will carry but if it goes to anarchy
than every single vote carries and
democracy pretty much never is a tan in
effect it is almost always anarchy yeah
so Chris I mean you know you know about
this is you read my editorial you listen
to Justin I talk about it yes is there
anything that sounds interesting about
this to you I think it's like it's like
you could be part of a hive mind right
like imagine yourself your goals it's
like the buggers and unders game is
imagine yourself in one of these
futuristic societies it's dystopian
places where you know you're you're
plugged into whatever external brain
that your brain becomes a part of you
know like it's your all directly you're
part of this like soup that is pulling
together to like cover something very
conquers that guys and very specific is
that guys yeah but yes I think it's just
fascinating to me to think about these
the gods like the way that this mass of
humanity could come together and the way
these different agendas pop up it's like
it's a whole like little feudal kingdoms
spring up I mean this this is
fascinating microcosm of community
involvement of you know like saboteurs
and white knights and it's just this
crazy drama is playing out with ups
downs A's B's how democracies an turkeys
and I think it's fascinating I think
it's like you can't like look directly
at it like you gotta like look at it for
your vision or something like that
because if you stare directly into put
twitch plays Pokemon you would go man
like the Ark of the confident so I mean
is Justin was talking about before like
people are there's religions that are
forming and basically the appeal as far
as I can understand is its emergence
narratives people are kind of creating
their own stories totally so I guess my
question is can a developer make
something like this or does it have to
be something that's wholly organic and
made by the people they was how do I
feel like this is just this whole thing
is just a test for that thing that the
twitch integration to troll player
what's that what's the game that's doing
that are you talking about Tetris no no
there's that game that's coming out that
has like the if you are streaming the
game twitch chat can troll you they can
make stuff happen thing I feel like this
will give on things to test for that huh
so I mean I guess bonito by the way
folks he's the engineer for our pod
Gonzalez is dropping the knowledge mom
so I guess so is it pop I mean if you
take away like the trolling aspect is it
possible for developer to actually make
this kind of thing to harness like the
emergent gameplay ass or emergent
narratives of this because it seems i
don't know i mean people say like oh you
could never make something purposeful
go viral but no no there are totally
people who construct oh yeah I roll
things just got my back the game is
daylight daylight daylight thank you
twitch so this so yeah I mean people
could construct something like this
purposefully I but I I think it's more
seeing what people are into like it's
not just twitch but the same thing that
we saw a flappy bird this kind of very
very normal game very what would seem to
most of us to be very boring but a whole
narrative sprung up around it that we
want to be a part of we want this kind
of quirky and different conflict that we
can feel like we're a part of and
interact with and I mean we don't get
that from regular Triple A games but
this kind of feels like the real world
that we all have a part in the gamers
are really a part of so do you agree
with that curse that we don't have that
in our triple o games that we don't have
what that kind of that kind of emergent
narrative or that kind of community I
got a community fascination I mean you
know you get like blips of it like
different shades of it in like a demon
souls or dark souls where you have that
community stuff people writing down and
coming into your game control you stuff
that's out of your control right I think
that this I'm trying to you know because
I'm trying to imagine a game in which
you would harness just a random like
group of people be in like a very low
functioning role but then you the player
so like let's say there's yet say
there's a battle game and these are and
like these giant warships are at battle
but like and you're the commander and
like it's not quite like like the
trickle down in like the systems and
that the guns your your ship develops or
the moves you make are in some way you
know determined by this chat melee of
people and yeah well to almost work the
best that you can with what they've
provided you or something I mean how
yeah well think about the way that Eve
was integrated with dust 514 yeah and
that you kind of recruited people and
dusty recruited people and Eve people
recruited dust people to fight these
wars yep but it was kind of like they
didn't have any direct control so it is
almost like that is yeah so that seems
like too many layers of abstract
right there's a lot of appeal of twitch
plays Pokemon is it's right there yeah
it's like instant everyone you know
everyone is it has an equal opportunity
of influencing it you know Kenda can tip
can like put their little finger on the
scale and see what happens and what
happens here is like you know it
translates in a very clear way in a way
that's easy to understand i think i
don't know about easy to understand i
don't have you watched it cuz it's kind
of crazy it's kind of curly if i didn't
have the CliffsNotes next to me i
wouldn't know what was going on it's
sure hey do you guys think what do you
guys think this is a fad or do you think
this is something that in some form will
carry on for the future to which place
Pokemon is a Fed yeah it's going to it's
gonna peter out of course sure well i'll
tell you sometime are people continuing
to do it like years well not just twitch
plays pokemon i'm talking about like
what we see games in some form like this
in the future or is this kind of like I
don't want I don't want to swear but
it's a cluster something I think no good
idea one things I love about the game
industry is you have these good ideas
these these little mechanics these
innovations that come into play and you
know maybe they don't catch on in a big
way it's not like oh that stick to cover
system oh yeah how everyone's going to
use that but they're sort of in the mix
and so developers are the sort of enter
the soup of what developers are thinking
of in terms of ways they can make games
and I think now that this is like a
landmark in terms of a community
interaction pulling together and and
just creating its own little vibrant
little nexus of play mm-hmm that's not
going to go ignored by game developers
at III HHH and tete also brought up
saltybet which is kind of salted that
was amazing saltybet was you watched two
fighters to really crazy fighters fun
twitch fighting they were AI controlled
and you bet on who would win maybe like
ryu vs like mr. kool-aid or something
like that and it was it was really fun
for a while and so yeah you get into
these narratives of like all Barney's
back oh it's good I know dad or like
always bet on dragon ball z aerators we
had that one and so you know like this
this is a phenomenon that so many people
it has this vibrancy in this
if the twitch community that you know
sort of gathers around this stuff that
no that's definitely not going away and
it'll definitely be interesting to see
you know who the spiritual successors
are to twitch plays pokemon or you know
what the next more ambitious twitch
plays game is going to be because you're
gonna be it is the kind of thing that
would be really hard for a company to
monetize though like how are you gonna
make money from this and heads is that
enough I don't know fifty thousand a day
for flappy bird so I had to do something
I guess okay so we're gonna wrap that up
and we're gonna play game before we end
the show all right you guys have to take
a card just take one card each don't
look at it so we're doing a metagame
meta game is kind of what it's like AB
samples that compares using don't live
in it or look at it don't look at it
don't look so I handed them both the
card in the card has a game name on it
like super mario brothers and i'm gonna
give them a category and they have two
on the spot think of something that fits
was in this category and argue it and
make it interesting i looked at my card
game so if the question is ah which game
is more overrated Justin and I both have
to argue that our game is more over time
you'd be like oh cuz halo it's just a
bunch of driving around warthogs and
you'd be like oh the call of duty's just
shooting dudes in it like you'd have to
make that argument but you don't believe
it okay so Chris yeah what you have to
do with your card you're going first we
have to do the same thing for both our
cards yes but you're going first okay
he's gonna go first so what you're gonna
do is you're gonna make a sequel of that
game that offers an in-depth
psychological analysis of the player of
the player yes all right yes and I look
at my cardinal get it right now and then
start start wounding us for the next
minute I can see it what am I not
supposed to see it how this is the worst
okay a sequel to Metal Gear Solid that
offers a Nintendo already do that
alright so in Metal Gear Solid uh vo cho
it's the eighth in the Metal Gear Solid
series the player starts off uh in just
like a normal suburban home it's let it
as like a really old dude the the kids
are sort of walking
round the family your snake and he's a
grandpa and he's settled down in
Pleasantville and as you sort of go
about your daily life you know you're
it's you have these sort of mass effect
style conversations conversation trees
uh you know you can go around the
neighborhood you can't go too far
because like your body's been through it
man yeah and so but a you know you go
through it and the people you're talking
to it aren't you know they at first they
start off in a sort of seems like normal
dialogue but then you know sometimes
they their questions get a little bit
probing this seems to be kind of a
neighborhood in which people are more
given to pontificating or to uh to come
pondering the big questions and then you
know it's really the whatever clothes
you have chosen to wear when you have
those conversations to determine what
kind of person you are oh that was a
twist at the end this is nice is very
Shyamalan twist yeah yeah okay just in
the same questions for you you have a
different game though what was the
question the question is you have to
make a sequel something in this universe
that offers an in-depth psychological
analysis that offers an in-depth
psychological of the player of the
player yes so funny that you should
mention a massive X tile dialogue tree
because my game is my mass effect oh
look at that um so does that mean I just
win no no no it's nothing to do with the
game you have it is all about the story
of your construct so the sequel to mass
effect is actually a prequel it's set on
earth and it follows the same mass
effect gameplay style except that there
are no battles there is only
conversation that you can have with
people and and the the conversation
choices that you make as you go along
affect the ending so there are one of 50
endings listed on the box but they're
all pretty much the same except they'd
be characters that you've interacted
with will show up in different parts of
the screen and the it so it uses cameras
and it uses connect or the PlayStation
camera and to judge you have to speak
out all of your narrative choices okay
it gives you a graph that shows you buy
at the end of the game it tells you the
tone of voice that you used and whether
you were kind or mean or or an idiot
based on how you talked and that's
that's how this mass effect prequel will
work but it's set on earth
and all of the choices that you make
will will retcon in to the a future Mass
Effect series right so if you go back
and you play mass effect one all of the
choices that you made in Mass Effect the
prequel which is mass effect 4 well
we'll have changed download a small
patch yeah small pouch in it it changes
the entire game but take one more card
each so both of you chose just entering
questions walk around and answering
questions which is early work hey man
Chloe work notes talking my mind was
about communicating communicating okay
um the National London Justin gone first
this time your game your equal in this
universe examines a divisive current
event device a divisive karna vent
through bit through the lens of there's
a lens of super meat boy oh this will be
fun okay so where we go with here a
divisive current event I I don't
actually want to do something too
serious like Kiev because that's sad and
I don't think there's a device if I
guess technically it would be a civil
war but a divisive current event would
be the the side for not fighting is a
good side of the Olympics ok and yet
canada vs america today on the hockey
game the house is going to work in Super
Meat Boy so super meat boy um is a
hockey player in the skin it's still a
2d scythes side scroller so you might
think that as a hockey game it's pretty
easy um but you have the the Canadians
in the mare you have to choose which
character is going to our which team is
going to win by sliding your your body
meet Ali into the into the goal and the
more times that you choose you it's not
a fun game i'm just gonna be doing this
over and over again you does the way
this place is very stained red it's like
it it lasts as long as a hockey game
which i think is roughly 10 to 12 hours
and you have to you have to continuously
take your character and put him into the
goal for that entire time entire
duration if you stop at any moment the
game resets and nobody wins so you want
to make sure that your team wins which
is either america or canada and and the
results after you do after you do this
go on to a leaderboard and which will
decide the actual winner of
in the Olympics but that is a quite a
way to examine a political issue sliding
me into a goal I would like to play that
game universe bonito is signed up he's
going to kick start your your idea all
right ah my game yeah you love you love
holding it up to the camera I don't know
what is is it really your favorite game
ever lost my favorite game ever hahaha
what is the political divisive event
that you are going to tackle well as we
all know ah the issue of gay marriage is
hugely divisive in not only the United
States of America but around the world
and gay rights continue to be a subject
that is a battleground politically and
morally spiritually etc etc so in the
sequel to spelunky I you are delving
into caves you are an above-ground
adventurer going through societies
across the world and the early levels
are fairly straightforward you go into
Salt Lake City Utah a city in a largely
conservative state that is actually
fairly progressive and the people you
encounter I hmm do you with some work so
there's got to be creatures right so in
any these urban environments are a
little bit outlandish they're still
there are rats running around you know
they're they're garbage can treasure
chests for you to loot as you try to
survive are there but occasionally you
know the instead of having shopkeepers
uh they have political rallies that
you'll come across and so whether you
know how you behave yourself in that
rally sort of influences like you know
are you picking up a sign that says it's
Adam and Eve not Adam and Steve or are
you on the side of one you know one love
for all mankind tougher levels take you
into more divisive areas are the final
secret hell
level is Nigeria where you have to
actually go in and you know be a gay
rights activist in there without getting
lynched or hacked up with a machete no
one has beaten it yet they're gonna vote
despite multiple multiple live stream or
spending hours and hours trying to do it
okay that was pretty interesting take
one more card um that was that got dark
in a hurry hey man you sent away civ
Chris you're going to the last one okay
um your sequel is going to be the top
story on fox news for an entire day what
is your gave you an entire eight
segments of the news cycle everybody's
gonna be really angry about this
everyone is in a huge furore because of
rogue to USA the art pack is rogue two
oh well you know how their games that
are roguelikes tom yeah raw rogue is the
original roguelikes okay so just call
what is this equal doing that's getting
it on Fox News oh well it's actually an
ultra liberal propaganda piece
pro-choice and in the beginning of it
you play as a tiny fetus and must battle
your way down the fallopian tube past
all sorts of morning-after pills and
other darker obstacles in order to be
born into the world and then and then
you wait which one is it prolite
pro-choice yeah yeah so uh you gotta get
lost it I should have done it the other
way around yeah yeah you gotta get it's
just really difficult you could die very
instantly because you're a little fetus
and you just have to make your way in
the world and clothe yourself in garbage
rags or else be shot by people who you
know other fetuses that have guns
because gun control is onyx
and uh you know if if uh yeah I don't
know Fox is waiting with this year now
Justin what do you what is your game
what are you doing this gonna lead fox
news so the the lead of fox news I have
to do i use this game what is it I have
scribe euless oh my god I cannot wait to
see this which I'm calling Scrabble
because I don't know what scrappy this
is that sounds like it's stupid game
scrabbles fine so it's scrubs gravel to
travel to the fox news learns about a
strange killer he breaks into a
preschool kills everybody they go
through his home and of course murder
mixed among the guns and used condoms in
lubricants and all the weird ephemera
they find multiple copies of Scrabble to
just laying about all over his apartment
and they discover through their
investigative reporting that you can
spell words like Hitler like death like
guns and gun and they see these scrabble
games laid out with all of these words
spelled out and I mean it takes the news
cycle there's a breaking story about 12
hours in where they they find out that
you can actually put together sentences
using the using these files and they
find in his apartment that he is spelled
out Hitler a nerf and grandma oh which
they they take to mean that there was
probably some incest that uh so I wasn't
going to choose a winner but I'm gonna
choose a winner because that was pretty
great that one does get help oh good but
that's it for the show oh it's just
we're doing stroma today so that's it
thank you thank you Justin so much for
playing along Thank You Thomas offering
some interesting ideas have to leave you
alone really appreciating Chris waters
is that a Thomas was alone it was toes
alone joke I gotta be worse so do we all
Justin ah thanks Tom that was fun thank
you nice little pod cast thingy and
thank you so much in veneto who is the
man behind the camera who knows things
such as daylight and other facts that we
had no idea about who's much
than all of us combined so yeah
handsomer thank you so much for watching
next week hopefully came down Ortiz back
have a good well please please